what does elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problem I
started a mentoring series with all the
tile learn from people who've done more
than us and by hanging around they're a
little bugger
hopefully some of their lines has their
eyes their beliefs their confidence keep
it on us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we can
learn from John Jocko willing in some of
his best motive each rule number one is
my personal favorite and unless you know
which ones do you guys like to buy and
as all the times as you watch this clip
see here something that really resonates
with you please leave it in quote it
comes below you might win a prize but
also we can write it down much more
likely to stick with yourself is enjoy
[Music]
you
where does discipline come from this
with it
internal force now sure of course you
could have discipline imposed on you by
some person like like a drill instructor
or like that self-help and
but the reality is that type of
disappointment this is a real type of
discipline that we're talking about that
this Clinton is strong it won't survive
what you need is self discipline how
much self discipline comes from the self
it comes from youth it comes from when
you make a decision to be disciplined
when you make a decision to be better
when you make a decision to do more and
to be more self discipline comes when
you decide that you're going to make a
mark on the world and if you think that
you're not disappointed or you can't
it's because you haven't yet decided to
begin it's because you haven't conceded
that disappointment yet
[Music]
so make the decision make that
completely different those foods quality
that will improve every aspect of your
life and remove better and stronger and
smaller and faster
and Houston
it'll make you free I don't really like
those words self-help or self management
or self-improvement I really like what
those words have come to mean these days
because there's a lot of people out
there that are constantly trying to
improve themselves by looking for the
one change the one change right the one
change in their life that's gonna make
their dreams come true and even worse on
top of that there's a lot of people out
there a lot of self-help gurus and these
hyperactive motivational speakers and
these other self-appointed modern Zen
yoga warriors that they're trying to
sell the one thing they're trying to
sell the nine steps or the enlightened
path that's going to allow you to unlock
all of your human potential and fulfill
the dreams so you can live the life that
you've you've always wanted to live now
I'm no guru and I definitely don't claim
to be I'm just a man but I will tell you
this it isn't one thing and it isn't ten
things and it isn't a hundred things
it isn't a quick path and there are no
shortcuts the meditation won't get you
there and neither will a miracle drug or
an organic supplement or some superfood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or all one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a daily a weekly at an
hourly fight an incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness and
against temptation and against laziness
it's a campaign of discipline the
campaign of hard work and dedication
it's waking up early and go
badly and grinding out every second in
between every single day so you want to
get better you want to self-improve stop
looking for a shortcut then go find your
alarm clock and find your discipline and
fling your guts and your passion and
your drive and find that you will and
then and then you will find your freedom
those days when I'm tired or worn out or
just basically sick of the grind well
what do I do
on those days I go anyways I get it done
even if I'm just going through the
motions I go through the motions I don't
really want to work out I work out I
really don't want to hammer on a project
I hammer on the project don't really
want to get up and get out of bed yeah I
get up and get out of bed now these
could be signals that you need some time
off and those signals might be right
they could be correct but don't take
today off today wait until tomorrow nope
don't give in the immediate
gratification that is whispering in your
ear shut that down do not listen to that
little voice instead go through the
motions lift the weights sprint the hill
work on the project
get out of bed now
as an overall rule I do not like
procrastination you need to get things
done but if you are going to rest that
is one thing that you should
procrastinate on that's the one thing I
want you to put off until tomorrow and
if when tomorrow comes you still feel
like you need to rest or you need to
take a break then okay take it but the
chances are you won't you won't need
that rest chances are you will realize
that the desire to rest was just
weakness it was just the desire to take
the path of least resistance that
downhill pass an easy path and by simply
going through the motions you overcame
that path and you stayed on the
righteous path the discipline path
you're stayed on the war path which is
right where you know that you belong I
want to tell you something else and I
want to make this clear don't just
listen don't just listen do I'm I'm not
just talking so you know I'm not just
talking I'm doing and I don't want you
to just listen put this information to
work make today count every day go
forward get aggressive
and a packet whether it's on the
battlefield or on the beat or in the
factory or on the farm or on the
construction site or on the website in
the garage or in the firehouse don't
hesitate step step forward and get after
it are so much knowledge out there so
much information so many ways to get
better and we make we make so many
mistakes whether were the product of our
mistakes and oftentimes the lesson is
sitting there right in front of our face
it's there to be learned but we miss it
or we don't pay attention to it or we
think we know better until it punches us
in the face
and the most important thing to learn is
that we have so much to learn we all do
and we can learn from school and from
people and from experience and we learn
from life but you have to process the
information you have to absorb it you
have to accept it you have to open your
mind you've got to free your mind so
that you can learn and make real
progress and as far as
regrets some things I wish I would have
done differently of course hindsight
hindsight is twenty-twenty and looking
back of course who wouldn't want to take
another go with something and improve on
the first try by doing it again and then
why not do it again and again and again
and why not just do it over and over
again until you have it perfect but the
fact is you don't get that chance you
get one shot one shot at this gig right
here life one life and that's all you've
gotten and regret in and of itself it's
worthless it does nothing for you
in fact the only valuable thing in
regret is the lesson you learned the
knowledge that you gained but walking
around filled with regret it gets you
nothing so learn and move on
don't let regret beat you down don't be
a slave to regret no let it teach you
let it make you better let the fear of
regret fuel you to take action today now
to take action now to become a better
person not filled with regret but filled
with knowledge filled
with knowledge and strength and power
and filled with life any type of danger
right gives you this flight-or-fight
response so train starts with training
jujitsu boxing Muay Thai wrestling
shooting competing competing right you
get used to those butterflies when you
compete you get those butterflies and
you get used to them and so train and
get used to seeing how that reaction
what that adrenalin feels like and and
also get used to understanding what the
superior action is right fight or flight
because sometimes flight is the correct
response sometimes fight is the correct
response but what you want to do is you
want to be able to assess and dictate
which response you're going to give and
not just do whatever your instincts
tells you because sometimes your
instinct might be wrong and so again I
don't know what you're actually you're
the situation where you're going into
but whatever it is because people get
the fight-or-flight response to do
everyday things to like public speaking
right lion rock climbing and that's why
I say let do you know do these things
training them so public speaking rock
climbing if you want to get get a rock
Michael you're gonna get over that
fight-or-flight response when you get
out go go rock climbing you're used to
it you scared of heights boots go start
parachuting you know you'll get used to
it you're scared of the water get worked
up and go through swimming and then give
come scuba certified just what the
things that you're not comfortable with
get comfortable with being uncomfortable
and while you're doing - while you're
doing them pay attention you got to
detach a little bit when these things
are when you're training to catch a
little bit and see what is going on your
mindset see what red flags that you can
see what things will make you aware of
the fact that your nerves or your
adrenaline and your if you feel yourself
clenching your fists you know okay so
customers has to be aware of it so that
you can change it so you can adjust it
and put your
again put yourself into these scenarios
and escalators they get harder harder
harder worse and worse and worse until
your until you start to get control of
these things one of my direct
subordinates one of my guys that work
for me he would he would call me up or
pull me aside with some major problems
some issue that was going on and he'd
say possibly got this and that and the
other thing and I look at him and I'd
say good and finally one day he was
telling me about some issue that he was
having some problem and he said I
already know what you're gonna say I
said well what am I going to say he said
you're gonna say good he said that's
what you always say when something is
wrong in going bad you always just look
at me and say good and I said well yeah
when things are going bad there's going
to be some good that's going to come
from it didn't get the new high speed
gear we wanted good didn't get promoted
one time you get better omission got
careful good we can focus on the other
one didn't get funded didn't get the job
you wanted got injured sprained my ankle
got tapped out
good job be
[Music]
unexpected problems good we have the
opportunity to figure out a solution
that's it when things are going bad
don't get all bummed out don't get
startled don't get frustrated
if you can save the word good guess what
the meter said oh hi
they means you're still believe me and
if you're still breathing
or now still got some fight left so get
up dust off reload recalibrate re-engage
go out on the attack
thank you thank you so much you I mean
I'd love to know what did you think when
you take this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow super life
over to your business let me know down
in the comments below I'm really curious
to find out I also want to give a
futuristic brand of 1% better thank you
so much brains and thinking there's a
couple of my book you're one word and
doing that awesome YouTube review on
your channel I really appreciate the
support man in a glass room joyful we
are happy to have you on the channel
thank you guys so much you watch these I
believe in you PT to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is let's love
see